do you know who paid for the
refurbishment of the prime minister's
flat
the uh prime minister met the cost of
the refurbishment of the flat
and that is very clear he's acted
completely in line with the rules
when did he meet those costs though
because there are allegations that a
donor paid a contractor
directly and that the boris johnson paid
him back which
would mean in the interim he effectively
had a loan
as i've said the prime minister met the
costs of the flat refurbishment
everything's been done in line with the
rules and i think
he's met them now he wants us to be folk
sorry
he met the questions now but but when
did he meet the cost that is that is key
isn't it because if
if somebody you shouldn't be
throughout this process we and he have
complied completely with the rules
and i think this is a huge distraction
from what people actually care about
which is
how we're dealing with the pandemic
we've just had the news that 50 percent
of people
in britain have now been vaccinated and
of course as trade secretary i'm working
on how we build our economy
after kovid in particular by striking
new trade deals that are going to drive
jobs and growth across the united
kingdom we will
come on to all of those points but but
really on the flat it is quite key and a
lot of people are very interested in it
most people have to save up if they want
to redecorate their flat
it appears here that either a donor paid
a contractor directly or the
conservative party
paid a contractor directly uh which was
it
the prime minister's met the cost of the
flat and as with all of these matters
meeting the cost of later dates
is the proper information has been
has been declared in the public domain
but
as you can imagine as trade secretary
i'm spending
i'm spending my time focused on trade
negotiations
not looking at flat refurbishments but
it hasn't been declared at all
and you know we're expecting it to
appear in the register of ministers
interests but the government hasn't
published that in fact
the ministerial code says it should be
published twice yearly but we only had
one last year in july
and the cabinet office has yet to
publish the latest installment which is
due at the end of 2020. so
it's actually not being declared and
it's only because
dominic cummings made these allegations
and because journalists have done some
digging that is now becoming clear
that boris johnson didn't pay for the
refurbishment out of his own pocket
initially initially he tried to get
somebody else to pay it and that is the
concern isn't it because if a donor is
paying for the refurbishment of the flat
uh he is then has a loan from that
donald or if the conservative party's
paying for it
that that is against the rules so it is
key isn't it to find out when he paid it
and to whom there was a statement made
to parliament at the end of
last week explaining the situation as
i've said the prime minister met the
costs of the flat refurbishment
and you know this is obviously important
that we declare costs in line with
the rules and that's what the prime
minister has has done
but fundamentally what people care about
is dealing with the covered pandemic and
that is what the prime minister is
spending his time
doing you keep saying that he has
declared it but but but he hasn't we
we don't know when he paid this money
and it's the timing isn't it it's
crucial have you had a conversation with
him about it before you
you came on this morning to do these
round of media interviews
as i've said i know that the prime
minister has
acted within the rules that he has
covered the cost
of the flat refurbishment himself and i
think that this
issue is a massive distraction from what
we should be focused on which is
how we are recovering from the pandemic
the vaccination programme
and the work we're doing to rebuild the
economy
um how do you know then that that he's
not broken the rules you must have had a
conversation with him he must have
told you when he paid it then if you if
you're convinced that you know he hasn't
broken the rules whereas dominic
cummings
told him that what he was doing was
potentially illegal
well i have been assured that the rules
have been fully complied with
and i know who assured you of that met
the course of the flat refurbishment
but who assured you of that
i absolutely believe and trust that the
prime minister has done that
we're not getting any really clear on on
the timing are we
um it's part of the problem as i've said
i've just spent the last week
negotiating
a new trade deal with australia it's
going to bring value to the british
economy i don't spend my time
getting involved in the details of the
flat refurbishment at number 10
and it's very clear that the prime
minister has met the cost of that
refurbishment
but but how do you know that he's
followed the rules then you know you you
said you've been assured that you um
you understand he's not broken the rules
you clearly have had a conversation
about it we're just really trying to
find out exactly when
he paid
well all of the details will be
given out in line with the rules and
there are certain reporting procedures
and those procedures are being followed
any idea when we will find out
as i said they will be reported in line
with the reporting procedures
but he is very clear that he has met the
cost of the flat refurbishment
they're already late though aren't there
as i mentioned to you about the
ministerial code
um you know they should have been
declared
months ago so they're not they're not
being declared on time
these costs have been outlined in line
with the ministerial code
of course the civil service is
responsible and
uh working with the prime minister to
make sure those things happen
but where have they been declared in the
ministerial code they haven't
as i've said these items are declared in
line with the ministerial code
the civil service make sure that happens
the prime minister has met the costs
and i'm very surprised that you're using
if they
interview you to ask the second question
again and again well it's because you're
not answering if they were declared in
the ministerial code we would have it
it would be in the public domain the
point is that it should have been
declared in the ministerial it was a
statement
there was a there was a statement made
to parliament on precisely this subject
at the end of last week
but that isn't the ministerial code
what people want to know is that in line
with the rules the prime minister has
met the cost of
this refurbishment that has happened
all the costs will be declared in line
with the rules
and that as far as i'm concerned
completely answers that question
okay it's part of the problem that we
don't have an independent advisor on
ministerial standards um sir alex allen
quit
in november didn't he over the pretty
patel bullying uh and the post has been
vacant
ever since uh sunday telegraph today
reporting that maybe a wobble from the
person who is meant to be
replacing them don't don't we need
somebody holding this government to
greater scrutiny
well of course it's important that that
role is appointed
so when when are we going to get
somebody in the role
well i understand that is about to
happen shortly
shortly any any clearer on timing with
that
i don't have any more details for you
i'm afraid on that
okay and other things that dominic
cummings mentioned in his blog last week
was about the lockdown leak
uh the so-called chatty rats incident uh
which is uh all about who and what uh
leaked stories about the the second
covert lockdown and
the central allegation is that the prime
minister tried to hold a leak inquiry to
protect the friend of his partner
um is the prime minister more worried
about his girlfriend's
friends than perhaps he is about the
safety of the country under covert
well the leak inquiry is ongoing and of
course
i hope that it finds who the
individual was who conducted this leak
because it's
very very unhelpful when confidential
information
is leaked from the government but why do
you think the prime minister it seems
tried to stop this leak inquiry then
as i've said before i mean this is title
tattle that's being
promoted and i don't think it really
addresses the key issues that people in
britain care about
i mean others would say it's actually a
really serious allegation if we're
trying to find out
the timings of of lockdowns and what the
motivation was
because it could potentially have saved
many many lives
but perhaps the most damning thing that
dominic cummings said
last week it is sad to see the prime
minister in his office fall so far below
the standards of competence and
integrity
that the country deserves i mean the
prime minister's been accused of
hiding donations cancelling inquiries to
protect friends
isn't dominick cummings right that he
has fallen below the standards of
integrity we need in a prime minister
well the prime minister and i work with
him very closely has been working flat
out to make sure we deal with this
terrible pandemic that we roll out the
vaccine program which has been
incredibly successful we've got half of
the people
in the united kingdom vaccinated now
and to make sure we deal with the crisis
and we also
work to build the economy back we work
to promote jobs and growth across
britain and
that is what people care about and you
know these
allegations and title tasks really are a
distraction from that key job and i know
the prime minister
is spending his time on what's important
which is dealing with the coverage
crisis
but working flat out is is different to
to not having integrity isn't it and
dominic grieve
yesterday said that he was a vacuum of
integrity johnny mercer said this week
it's the most distrustful awful
environment
it's rather windy out here
you're doing ever so well battling
against the elements i'll i'll i'll just
ask you that again
well well done for not getting hit on
the head um
i'll just re-ask that dominic grieve
said that that the prime minister's
vacuum of integrity
johnny mercer has said uh in that
government almost nobody tells the truth
um i don't think anyone can really get
on the high horse about trust and ethics
all the rest of it in politics because
as far as i'm concerned
most of it is a bit of a cesspit now
these are quotes from conservatives
they're not from the opposition
about your leader are they wrong
it's it's completely wrong the prime
minister
who i work very closely with has
consistently through this crisis
acted in the best interest of the
country
you know we've had a huge success in
this vaccination program was thanks to
the decision of the prime minister and
my colleagues across government we're
now working hard to rebuild the
economy and these noises off are simply
not helpful they're not contributing to
a positive future
and they don't reflect what is actually
going on
in downing street well potentially not a
positive feature for boris johnson
i mean i mean it's it's odd isn't it
because he does appear to be a really
sort of affable evoncular chap when he's
in front of the tv cameras
but the picture that's emerging from
those who work closely with him
seems really very different the
journalist eddie mayer once rather
boldly accused the prime minister of
being
in his words a nasty piece of work was
that was there a grain of truth in that
i work very closely with the prime
minister he is doing a fantastic job
in very difficult circumstances and i
think you can see the result of that in
the success of the vaccine program
what we're doing to rebuild the economy
what we're doing in trade we've just
recently agreed with the australians
that we are
striking this trade deal which is going
to bring thousands of jobs across the
united kingdom
and that is what the british people are
focused on and that is why
he has such support across the country i
did promise we would come on to trade
um and you brought it up again then of
course as you say you've had talks this
week with dan tahan
the trade minister um slightly
embarrassing
leak uh from a source close to you
earlier in the week saying that you plan
to sit him down in an uncomfortable
chair
so he had to deal with you directly for
nine hours he needs to show he can
play it at your level did he play at
your level
well that's a complete load of nonsense
what appeared in the press the fact is
that
dan and i have a very positive
relationship we had
really positive talks over the last two
days we're now within a glimpse of
striking our first
post-brexit trade deal which is
negotiated from scratch
and i'm looking forward to agreeing that
in principle
in the next few weeks and this will
bring huge benefits to the british
economy whether it's the whiskey
industry
the car industry the financial services
industry
and it also opens up huge opportunities
for us in the asia pacific market
one of the fastest growing parts of the
world and i'm looking forward to
building that even further is australian
wine going to become a little bit
cheaper
well that is one of the many benefits
that there will be from the australia
trade deal
okay um covered you mentioned as well
we've seen some really distressing
scenes from india over the last couple
of days haven't we
um and there is obviously great concern
about the uh so-called indian variant
there are now
uh according to phe 132 cases
of that variant in the uk three that
weren't linked to travel from india how
worried are you about this
well the situation in india is extremely
worrying i had a call last week with my
indian counterpart we're working to do
what we can to support
the indian government particularly in
areas like oxygen we're putting together
a package of support
but it is a deeply concerning situation
and my
thoughts and prayers go out to the
people of india
is there any evidence that the indian
variant can
escape vaccine protection
there is no evidence of that at this
stage but of course we're constantly
monitoring
the variants and the impact they have on
the vaccination programme
to make sure we're able to deal with it
deal with that
but as i said my thoughts are really
with the indian population and we are
doing all we can to help
india deal with the terrible tragedy
that is happening
in their country is there a possibility
that it could slow down the easing of
the lockdown here in the uk if these
figures start going up here
we're still on track with our road map
we're constantly monitoring to make sure
that we're able to deal
with any new variants that emerge and
make sure our vaccination programme
always works to be able to do that
there are some people who've pointed out
that it took several days for travel
from india to the uk to actually stop
would you like to have seen it happen a
bit quicker
well when we did announce the
travel ban we do need to make sure that
that can be
operationalized at the borders so that
was important to have that gap to be
able to get the borders
arrangements in place